-- Captions by VITAC --
www.vitac.com
>> THE CLEVELAND CA CAVALIERS
SELECT THE BRIAN JAMES.
>> HERE HE COMES.
>> THE LAST 25 FOR THE CAVALIERS
FOR THE BRIAN JAMES.
-- LeBRON JAMES.
>> I'M GOING TO TAKE MY TIME.
>> NOT TWO COULD NOT THREE COULD
NOT FIVE NOT SIX.
NOT SEVEN.
>> LeBron: I AM LeBRON JAMES
FROM AKRON, OHIO.
I'M NOT EVEN SUPPOSED TO BE H
HERE.
WHAT EVERYONE SAYS ABOUT ME ON
THE COURT DON'T MATTER BECAUSE I
A, NO WORDS.
>> BLOCKED BY JAMES!
>> LeBron: WHEN I DECIDED TO
COME HERE, THE EXCITEMENT.
>> THE LAKER NATION WANT THEIR
RESPECT.
>> THE BROAD JAMES IS NOW NUMBER
TWO IN THE HISTORY OF THE NBA.
>> HELLO, LOS ANGELES.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
WE NEED MORE ENERGY THAN THAT.
HELLO, L.A.
THERE WE GO.
I WILL TAKE IT.
MY NAME IS TAYLOR ROOKS.
I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE WITH YOU
GUYS TO CELEBRATE 20 YEARS OF
GREATNESS POWERED BY AT&T 5G.
I WAS THINKING 20 YEARS IS SUCH
A LONG TIME.
FIRST OFF, RAISE YOUR HAND IF
YOU ARE 20 YEARS OLD IN HERE OR
LESS.
TRUE.
SO FOR YOU ALL, THAT ARE RAISING
THEIR HANDS OVER HERE THAT HE
HAS BEEN DOING THIS YOUR ENTIRE
LIFE.
OKAY?
SINCE 2003.
THAT NUMBER ONE BOX OFFICE MOVIE
IN 2003 WAS "FINDING NEMO."
THE NUMBER ONE SONG WAS "IN THE
CLUB" BY 50 STENT -- 50-CENT.
IT HAS BEEN A LONG TIME THAT
BRAUN HAS BEEN DOING THIS.
SO MANY HIGHLIGHTS THAT SO MANY
GOOD SHOTS, SO MANY AMAZING
MOMENTS LeBRON HAS PROVIDED US
AND WE ARE GOING TO COUNT DOWN
HIS 20 BEST HEADLIGHTS.
TO DO THAT, I NEED SOME HELP.
I GOT MY GOOD FRIENDS HERE WITH
ME.
MR. CHANNING FRYE AND MR. NICK
YOUNG, GIVE IT UP FOR THESE TWO.
[ APPLAUSE ]
COME ON OVERCOAT BOYS.
-- OVER, BOYS.
ARE WE GOING WITH NICK OR SWANKY
P?
>> I AM SWAGGY TONIGHT.
>> Taylor: A LOT OF BLONDE
HIGHLIGHTS.
THESE WERE PICKED BY THE FANS.
OVER 100,000 USERS VOTED IN THE
APP.
YOU PUT THE ORDER OF THESE TOP
20.
IT WAS NOT US.
I'M VERY INTERESTED TO SEE WHAT
KIND OF CAME ON TOP.
SO HOW ARE YOU FEELING, LeBRON
IS A GOOD FRIEND AND YOU HAVE
SEEN A LOT OF HIS CAREER.
WHAT DOES IT REPRESENT?
>> THE FACT THAT I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PLAY AND WIN A
CHAMPIONSHIP WITH HIM WAS HUGE.
I DID HATE LeBRON A LOT EARLY
ON BECAUSE IT FELT LIKE HE WAS
UNSTOPPABLE.
WHEN YOU SEE THAT WORK THAT HE
PUTS IN EVERY DAY, YOU
UNDERSTAND WHY HE HAS HAD THE
ON-CHIP DEPICT THERE IS NO
PLAYER I'VE PLAYED WITH OR THING
THAT HAS COMMITTED TO BASKETBALL
WITHIN LeBRON JAMES.
HE SPENDS MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
ON HIS BODY, HIS MIND AND I'M
SURE IT IS MORE THAN THAT.
HE IS AN AWESOME DUDE.
HE IS A BETTER COMPETITOR.
>> Taylor: I LOVE THAT.
I ASSUME THERE'S A LOT OF
LeBRON FANS IN HERE.
PLEASE MAKE SOME NOISE, BIG
LeBRON FANS.
THIS IS ARE PROUD.
WHAT ABOUT YOU, S SWAGGY P.
>> LONGEVITY.
HE IS STILL FLYING AND I CAN'T
DUNK NO MORE.
SO FOR ME, JUST TO SEE THAT OR
HE PUT IN, STILL OUT THERE
DOING, UNBELIEVABLE.
>> Taylor: WITH 20 YEARS IN
GREATNESS, THAT THERE'S GOING TO
BE A LOT OF STUFF THAT WE
MISSED.
RIGHT NOW, WE'RE GOING TO SHOW
YOU THE HIGHLIGHTS THAT DID NOT
MAKE THE CUT.
RUN THE TAPE.
>> OH!
OH MY!
>> KING JAMES.
YES!
61 FOR LeBRON JAMES.
>> GUARDING LeBRON.
WOW.
7 FOR 7 ON THE CAVALIERS.
[ WHISTLE BLOWING ]
>> IT IS GOING IN.
>> YOU DON'T EVER WANT TO BE
SOMEONE ELSE'S HIGHLIGHT REEL.
>> THEY GIVE INTO LeBRON.
LeBRON!
HE DOES!
>> Taylor: THOSE MISSED THE CUT.
WHICH OF THOSE STICK OUT TO YOU,
CHANNING?
ARE YOU SURPRISED?
>> Channing: NO, THE ONE THAT I
THOUGHT WAS THE FUNNIEST AND
MOST DISRESPECTFUL WAS WHEN HE
WAS SPINNING THE BALLPARK I WAS
ON THE BENCH LIKE NO, HE JUST
DID THAT?
HE WAS ALREADY ON FIRE.
HE HAD ALREADY DUMPED ON
SOMEBODY.
THE FACT THAT HE WAS JUST
SPITTING THE BALL IN FRONT OF
HIS FACE, IT WAS LIKE SHOOT
AROUND, WE WERE LAUGHING ON THE
BENCH.
IT SHOWS YOU, LIKE, WHEN YOU ARE
IN THE RESULT LIKE THAT, IT DOES
NOT MATTER WHAT YOU DO.
>> Taylor: I SEE YOU LAUGHING
OVER THERE.
>> LIKE OKAY, COME T GET THIS.
>> Taylor: LET'S GET TO THE 20
THAT DID MAKE IT.
LET'S START WITH THOSE 20 TO 16?
LET'S SEE.
♪
>> HERE HE COMES THE OTHER WAY.
FOR IT IS THE FIRST OF HIS
CAREER.
>> I REMEMBER THAT FIRST GAME IN
SACRAMENTO.
GOTTA BREAK AWAY DUNK.
THE CROWD WAS GOING CRAZY.
TERRIFIC CAREER AS YOU KEEP
GOING.
>> WATCH THIS ONE.
WOW, WHAT A START.
HE HAS IT IN FRONT.
OUT OF BOUNDS.
>> IT PROBABLY JUST COMES DOWN
TO THE ONE IN MILWAUKEE WHERE HE
THROWS THE PASS AND HE HAS HIS
ARMS OUTSTRETCHED AND LeBRON
IS HUNTING IT BECAUSE OF HOW
ICONIC THAT PHOTO WAS.
>> LeBRON DROPS THE ANNVILLE.
HOLY SMOKES.
>> A NEW SHOT CLOCK.
PUTTING IT HOME.
>> EVERYONE THOUGHT THE BALL WAS
GOING TO CUT THE CORNER THERE.
>> HE MAKES THE CATCH.
TURN AROUND THREE ON THE WAY.
HE MAKES IT IN!
LeBRON JAMES EXCEEDED IN WITH
RETURNS OF A SECOND -- 3/10 OF A
SECOND REMAINING.
♪
>> HE COMES OUT TODAY!
LOOK AT HIM.
>> THAT IS WHAT THEY CAME TO S
SEE.
>> WATCH.
HE THROWS.
HE LOOKS AT THE GUY.
HE SAYS SOMETHING.
THEN HE GETS INTO THE STEP.
LEG JOG.
LEG JOB.
THEY ARE GOING CRAZY.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Taylor: SO GOOD.
ONE OF THE THINGS ABOUT THESE
VIDEOS IS ALMOST AS GOOD AS THE
HIGHLIGHT IS LeBRON'S
REACTIONS AND THE CROWD
REACTIONS AND ONE OF THE THINGS
I LOVE ABOUT THAT IS THAT ONE
YEAR THEY SHOW BRADLEY'S WIFE
AND SHE IS LIKE, I CAN'T BELIEVE
HE JUST DID THIS.
>> TALKING THE WHOLE GAME, WHICH
IS GREAT.
HE DEFINITELY LOOKED AT HER AND
SHE WAS LIKE, I HATE YOU,
LeBRON.
>> Taylor: SHE IS SO FUNNY.
>> I THOUGHT ABOUT IT FOR A
SECOND.
I SAID, NOPE, NOPE.
>> Taylor: AS A COMPETITOR,
RIGHT, YOU ARE GOING AGAINST
LeBRON.
HE HAS ONE OF THESE MOMENTS.
WHAT DOES IT DO TO YOU?
>> WELL, I MEAN, WHEN I FIRST,
THE LEAGUE, THEY WERE SAYING YOU
CAN'T DO NOTHING TO HIM.
IF YOU TRY TO FOLLOW, HE WILL
TAKE YOU WITH THAT TO THAT RIM.
THERE'S NOTHING YOU COULD REALLY
DO AND ONCE HE STARTED GETTING
EVERYTHING, THE JUMP SHOTS,
GETTING USED TO JUST COMING AT
PEOPLE AND COULD NOT STOP HIM.
>> Taylor: ABSOLUTELY.
THE FIRST ONE YOU SAW THAT WAS
HIS DEBUT IN OCTOBER 2003.
HE FINISHED THAT WENT WITH 25
POINTS AND NINE ASSISTS.
DID YOU KNOW FROM THE MOMENT HE
CAME INTO THE LEAGUE WHAT HE WAS
GOING TO BE?
DID IT TAKE YOU A MINUTE?
>> THE VIDEO DOES IT KNOW
JUSTICE.
HE IS 6'9", 260.
WHEN I TOLD YOU HE IS ONE OF THE
MOST EXPLOSIVE LIKE IMAGINE THAT
LAKERS HIGHLIGHT THAT HE WAS 36
YEARS OLD.
HE USED TO JUMP SO FAST AND SO
VIOLENT, THERE WAS NOTHING.
CENTERS BOUNCE OFF OF HIM.
THAT IS THE THING THAT IS SCARY
ABOUT HIM AND HIS TRANSFORMATION
OVER THE YEARS IS THAT HE WAS
NOT SUPPOSED TO BE A SCORER AND
HE HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO BEAT
THE SCORING RECORD.
HE HAS TAKEN SOME OF THAT WRIST
TEAMS TO THE NBA FINALS WE MAY
EVER SEE.
FOR ME --
>> Taylor: WHAT ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT, CHANNING?
>> IF HE IS -- IT IS JUST
AMAZING HOW ATHLETIC HE STAYED
TO BE ALMOST 40 YEARS OLD.
>> Taylor: ABSOLUTELY.
WE ARE GOING TO DO A QUICK FIVE
CHECK POWERED BY ATG 5G -- AT&T
5G.
LOOKING AT THESE PLAYS, I NEVER
UNDERSTAND THE HATE HE GETS.
HE HAS SOME OF THE MOST
DISRESPECTFUL POSTERS OVER.
I GREET WITH ALL THREE.
WHY DO YOU THINK HE GETS THE
HATE THAT HE GETS?
>> BECAUSE HE IS A NICE GUY.
THEY WANT SUPERSTARS TO HAVE
THAT MENTALITY AND LeBRON GETS
ALONG WITH EVERYBODY THROUGHOUT
THE COURT.
THAT SITE DON'T COME OUT.
ABOUT TO TAKE POINTS.
THAT BOY GET BUCKETS.
YOU GOT TO GET GET HIM HIS
RESPECTS.
HE IS ABOUT TO BE NUMBER SIX.
>> Taylor: ABSOLUTELY, AND YOU
CANNOT STOP IT.
SO IT MORE OF THIS VIBE CHECK.
LET'S HEAD OUT TO PIERRE
ANDRESEN WHO IS TALKING SOME --
TO SOME LAKERS FANS.
WHAT UP, PIERRE?
>> Pierre: WE ARE HERE AT THE
VIBE CHECK POWERED BY AT&T 5G.
AND TRACE OBVIOUSLY WE ARE HERE
COUNTING DOWN LeBRON'S BIGGEST
HIGHLIGHTS.
WHAT IS YOUR PERSONAL FAVORITE
LeBRON HIGHLIGHT?
>> I WAS A HEAT FAN BEFORE I WAS
A LeBRON FAN.
WHEN HE MADE THE DECISION TO
COME, THAT WAS GREAT FOR ME.
HE HAS BEEN GIVING THE CELTICS
HELL.
MY FAVORITE HIGHLIGHT HAS TO BE
THEY ARE IN THE BACK COURT AND
MARIO HAS THE FIELD.
TOSSING IT UP LeBRON YAMS IT
ON JASON TERRY.
>> Pierre: SHOUT OUT TO JASON
TERRY.
THAT IS AN INCREDIBLE HIGHLIGHT.
WE WANT TO ENJOY THE CRYPTO
ARARENA.
GO SEE THAT BOY UP CLOSE IN
PERSON.
TAYLOR BACK TO YOU.
>> Taylor: THANKS SO MUCH,
PIERRE.
THIS LEADS TO ANOTHER POINT.
I WANT TO DO A VIBE CHECK IN
THIS ROOM.
HONESTY HOUR.
WHO WAS A LAKERS FAN.
LAKERS FAN BEFORE THE BROAD?
OKAY.
WHO IS ADMITTEDLY  AND LeBRON
FAN?
SEE?
I LIKE IT.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE THAT
WAY, WHICH IS FINE.
YOU KNOW?
WHAT DO YOU THINK WHEN YOU LOOK
AT LAKERS FANS?
PURE LeBRON FANS?
>> MAJORITY.
I FEEL THE LAKERS IS AMAZING
PLACE, AMAZING CITY AND THAT
LOCKER ROOM IS SPECIAL.
I GREW UP IN PHOENIX, SO I'M A
SON'S FAN.
BUT BEING ABLE TO PUT ON THAT
LAKERS JERSEY IS AN HONOR.
>> Taylor: IT IS A GREAT FAN
BASE BUT I THINK LeBRON HAS
SOME OF THE MORE FIERCE FANS
THAT EXIST.
DON'T THINK ABOUT SAYING
ANYTHING ABOUT LeBRON ON
INSTAGRAM.
THEY WILL COME FOR YOU.
THEY PROBABLY HAVE THE MOST
RABID FAN BASES.
LET'S GET TO THE REST OF THE
HIGHLIGHTS AND START WITH 15.
>> BREAKAWAY FOR THE CAVS.
CLEVELAND, OHIO.
>> THAT EXTENSION.
>> LeBRON, FISCAL THREE
SECONDS LEFT IN THE CLOCK.
WHAT ARE YOU TELLING YOUR
TEAMMATES?
>> LeBron: KEEP THE BALL.
>> JAMES, TWO SECONDS.
FOR THAT WIN!
LeBRON JAMES LIVERS!
IT IS A WINNER IN CLEVELAND!
-- DELIVERS!
>> I CALLED IT OUT BEFORE IT
HAPPEN.
I REMEMBER WATCHING THAT GAME.
I SAID, LeBRON ABOUT TO DUNK
ON SOMEBODY.
>> LeBRON JAMES WITH NO REGARD
FOR HUMAN LIFE!
>> I JUST GOT HYPED.
I TOLD YOU ALL.
>> HE CAME DOWN AND WAS ABOUT TO
JUMP AND HE DUNKED IT.
I WAS LIKE, I REMEMBER WATCHING
IT AT THAT AGE.
THE PLAY THAT ALWAYS STOOD OUT
TO ME.
>> AND WHEN LeBRON WENT UP,
BOTH OF OUR CHEERS WENT
BACKWARDS.
THEY WERE WATCHING IN CLEVELAND
THAT NIGHT.
>> TWO ON ONE.
>> YES!
AND THE CROWD!
MY GOODNESS.
[ BUZZER ]
♪
>> INSIDE!
THE BENCHES GOING NUTS!
>> POWERFUL, LeBRON JAMES.
♪
>> Taylor: I LOVE THE AMOUNT.
NICK, THAT ONE WHERE HE FINISHED
THAT THAT WAS YOUR ROOKIE YEAR.
YOU DID NOT PLAY THAT GAME.
>> Nick: NO, I THINK IT WAS
PLAYOFFS.
I WAS LIKE, THIS MAN DOING THIS
IN PLAYOFFS.
ALL I REMEMBER IS MY TEAMMATE
ALMOST GOT EXCITED LIKE I WAS ON
THE TEAM.
LIKE THAT YOU CAN'T DO THAT
HERE.
MY BAD.
IT WAS AMAZING, MAN.
IT IS THE STUFF YOU DO OUT
THERE.
YOU ARE DOING IT IN THE PRIME
GAME WHEN THE GAME IS ON THE
LINE AND IT IS LeBRON.
>> Taylor: YEAH.
WAS THERE A POINT WHEN YOU GOT
USED TO IT?
DID YOU GET USED TO SEEING THESE
TYPES OF HIGHLIGHT PLAYS EVERY
GAME?
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU SORT OF DO INTEND YOU SEE IN
THE FINALS, WHERE HE STARTS
GETTING USED TO AND YOU START
LOOKING AT THE STATS SHEETS.
HE DOES IT ONCE AND THEN HE DOES
IT AGAIN AND HE DOES IT AGAIN.
THIS MAN IS NOT HUMAN.
AND THEN HIS ABILITY TO DO THAT
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN
AGAINST THE CREAM OF THE CROP IS
WILD TO ME.
HE IS NOT REALLY A GOOD 3-4
SHOOTER AND THEN IS HE GOING TO
BE TIRED?
THAT ONE WAS CRAZY TO ME.
THERE'S NOTHING THAT HE IS NOT
ELITE AT?
>> Taylor: ABSOLUTELY.
NICK, YOU BROUGHT IT UP.
WHEN YOU WERE A ROOKIE, YOU
RECEIVED LeBRON DO THESE
THINGS AND YOU ARE STILL AMAZED.
YOU ARE DIGESTING THE FACT THAT
THIS IS NOW YOUR COMPETITION AT
ONE THING I HAVE SEEN IS WHETHER
I'M INTERVIEWING JOHN OR JASON,
THE SAKE THEY WANT TO GET A
HIGHLIGHT ON LeBRON JAMES.
LET'S HEAR SOME OF HIS PEERS
TALK ABOUT LeBRON.
>> WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT LeB
LeBRON, YOU THINK ABOUT
GREATNESS.
I THINK IT IS MORE A MARBLE THE
THING I LOVE THE MOST IS HOW
CONSISTENT HE IS, ALWAYS GOOD
FOR HIS TEAM.
EVEN THOUGH HE SCREEN LAST, HE
WAS ALWAYS THERE.
SHE EXCEEDED EVERY EXPECTATION
EVERYBODY PUT ON HIM.
-- HE EXCEEDED EVERY EXPECTATION
I MEAN, YEAH, CLOSE.
HE IS GOING TO PLAY FOR LIKE 25
SEASONS.
>> IT IS CRAZY.
I AM IN LOVE WITH HIM, BROKE.
>> I THINK SOME OF MY FAVORITE
PLAYS ARE FROM HIS LAST YEAR.
>> LOOK OUT BELOW!
>> IN YOU, 19, TO DO THAT KIND
OF DUNK IS EXTREMELY IMPRESSIVE.
IN YEAR 19, IS UNBELIEVABLE.
>> OH MY LOAD.
>> THAT WAS A VERY DOPE PLAY
BECAUSE I WAS INVOLVED IN IT.
>> POWERS UP AND LAYS IT IN AND
THERE HE IS, LeBRON JAMES
MOVES TO NUMBER THREE OF THE
NBA'S ALL-TIME SCORING LIST.
>> THEY ENDED UP THROWING HIM
THE BALL.
SLICED OVER AND HE HAD A LAYUP.
ANOTHER BIG PLAY FOR ME.
>> WHAT IS YOUR FAVORITE
LeBRON PLAY?
>> I'M GOING TO SAY MY BLOCK ON
HIM ON CHRIS.
THAT IS WHAT I REMEMBER.
>> SIX SECONDS REMAIN.
DEFLECTED OUT OF BOUNDS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> IN THE COURT, HE HAS BEEN MY
RIVAL.
I GIVE THE MAN HIS FLOWERS.
HE HAS DONE THINGS THAT EVERY
KID WANT TO DO.
>> I ASKED, WHAT IS HIS FAVORITE
LeBRON HIGHLIGHTS?
HE SAID, THE BLOCK I HAD ON
LeBRON.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> WHAT IS WRONG WITH THAT, MAN?
WHAT IS WRONG WITH THAT, MAN?
[ LAUGHTER ]
♪
>> Taylor: I LOVE THAT.
WANT TO GIVE YOU THE FLOOR
BECAUSE I THINK YOU MIGHT HAVE A
GOOD LeBRON HIGHLIGHT THAT
ACTUALLY INCLUDES YOU?
>> Nick: I WAS A ROOKIE, YOU
KNOW?
I WAS -- HE PULLED UP.
HE LOOKED ME UP AND DOWN LIKE I
WAS NOTHING AT FIRST.
HE MISSED IT.
THE BALL WENT, OF FAR END GOT
THE REBOUND.
IT WAS ME AND HIM ON A FAST
BREAK.
HE MUST THINK I COULD NOT JUMP
OR SOMETHING.
HE JUMPED.
THAT WAS NICE.
>> Taylor: HOW MUCH DID THAT
LOOK UP AND DOWN, FEEL YOU TO
WANT TO DO THAT?
>> Nick: I WAS ON CLOUD.
I WAS LOOKING AT TOP 10 ALL
NIGHT.
THEY TOOK THE TAPE AND HIT IT.
>> Taylor: THEY GOT TO HAVE
LeBRON GOT IT LOOK GOOD AT ALL
TIMES.
ONE THING THAT WAS SAID THAT I
THINK IS VERY IMPORTANT IS IT IS
NOT JUST THAT HE IS GREAT.
IT IS NOT JUST THAT HE HAS BEEN
DOING IT FOR 20 YEARS AND HAS
THIS LONGEVITY.
IT IS THAT HE BECAME EVERYTHING
EVERYONE SAID HE WAS GOING TO BE
AND THAT IS ONE OF THE MOST
FICKLE THINGS THAT YOU CAN DO
NOT JUST IN SPORTS BUT IN LIFE.
HE HAS HAD CONSTANT PRESSURE,
CONSTANT EXPECTATIONS AND HE
CONTINUES TO SUPPRESS THAT.
WHAT YOU THINK?
>> I TRIED TO SAY THIS AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE.
AS BASKETBALL PLAYERS, SOME OF
US ARE TRIED TO EARN MINUTES,
LeBRON FROM THE AGE OF 16 WAS
LOOK, I'M TRYING TO BE THE BEST
PLAYER EVER.
SO HE LOOKS AT THE GATE A LOT
DIFFERENTLY.
WHEN HE GETS THE SCHEDULE, HE IS
LOOKING AT, OKAY, I NEED TO
SWITCH MY DIET UP DURING THIS
TIME BECAUSE WE ARE PLAYING MORE
GAMES OR A NEED THIS GUIDE TO BE
THIS GOOD BECAUSE THIS TEAM HAS
DONE THIS.
LeBRON'S BRAIN WORKS IN A WAY
THAT I HAVE NEVER SEEN MAYBE TWO
GUYS HAVE HAD BRAIDS LIKE THAT,
INCLUDING STEVE NASH.
THOSE GUYS ARE HALL OF FAME
RESPECT FOR LeBRON TO COME
INTO THE LEAGUE AND CONTINUE IS
CRAZY.
THERE HAS NEVER BEEN A ANOTHER
PLAYER WITH MORE PRESSURE FROM
THE AGE OF 15, 16, THEN LeBRON
AND NOBODY MORE DOCUMENT IT.
WE KNOW EVERY SINGLE PART OF
LeBRON'S LIFE.
WE KNOW HIS FAMILY.
WE KNOW EVERYTHING AND I THINK
THAT IS WHY SOMETIMES HE GETS AS
MUCH HATE BECAUSE HE IS NOT
HIDING AWAY, KEY IS OR WHO HE
BELIEVES OR HIS OPINIONS.
HE IS LIKE THAT THIS IS WHAT I
THINK.
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO TAKE THAT
AND THAT IS A THEORY IN LIFE.
>> Taylor: ABSOLUTELY.
AND AL ALL OF US KNOW THAT IT TS
A LOT TO MAKE THEIR BODIES,
THEIR SUCCESS A FULL-TIME JOB.
TALK ABOUT THE DISCIPLINE THAT
LeBRON IS PRACTICING DAY IN
AND DAY OUT?
>> LeBRON THE MORNING, HE SEES
IT ALL.
YOU SPEND THAT MUCH ON YOUR
BODY.
YOU GOT TO BE IN THE RIGHT
MENTAL STATE.
I DON'T GOT AS MUCH MONEY TO
SPEND ON MY BODY.
I WORK WITH WHAT I HAVE.
WITH SOMEBODY LIKE LeBRON TO
COME IT WITH THAT MUCH PRESSURE
AND PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT HIM
BECAUSE HE HAD A HOVER IN HIGH
SCHOOL AND THEY WANT HIM TO BE
WHO HE WAS AND HE IS THE
GREATEST.
ONE OF THE GREATEST.
>> Taylor: A HUMMER IN HIGH
SCHOOL.
LET'S KEEP THE PILOTS GOING.
MORE HIGHLIGHTS, PLEASE.
♪
>> BEHIND THE BACK STRETCH.
HERE COMES LeBRON AGAIN!
>> I SAID, YOU KNOW WHAT, THAT
IS AN ACCIDENT.
TWO TIMES, THREE TIMES.
BY THE FOURTH TIME I SAID, OKAY,
HE MEANT TO DO THAT.
THAT IS WHY HE IS KING JAMES.
>> MY FAVORITE LeBRON CLIP HAS
TO BE WHEN HE IS DUNKING OUT ON
JAMES JOHNSON AGAINST CHICAGO.
THAT WAS JUST LIKE JUST A FORCE
IN HOW HIGH HE WAS BUT THAT WAS
PROBABLY THE CRAZIEST HIGHLIGHT
AND MY FAVORITE.
>> JOHNSON.
>> NO TIMEOUT REMAINING FOR
CLEVELAND TO PICK UP THE BALL.
♪
>> THROWS UP THE POINTER.
GOOD NIGHT, CLEVELAND!
THAT IS FOR YOU!
>> I LIVE FOR THOSE MOMENTS TO
COME THROUGH FOR MY TEAM.
IT IS A GREAT FEELING TO DO THAT
AND MY GUYS, THEY TRUST ME.
>> THE GREATEST SHOT BLOCK OF
ALL TIME THAT I HAVE SEEN WAS
PROBABLY LeBRON IN THE NBA
FINALS.
>> OH, WHAT A BLOCK FROM JAMES!
>> THAT BLOCK CAME OUT OF
NOWHERE.
HE GOT IT AT THE RIM AND YOU CAN
SEE "BLE LeBRON'S ARM IN THE BA.
>> THE STRENGTH.
>> HE GETS IT TO LeBRON.
YES!
LeBRON JAMES AT THE BUZZER!
>> WHAT DWIGHT REMEMBER MOST?
I HAVE HAD TO WATCH IT TIME
AFTER TIME AFTER TIME FOR THE
LAST 13 YEARS AROUND PLAYOFF
TIME.
IF I HAD MY DEFENDER ON THE
BALL, TRACKING LeBRON JAMES,
WE MIGHT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO TAKE
THAT SHOT AWAY.
>> THAT IS WHAT MVPs DO, THOSE
KIND OF SHOTS.
♪
>> Taylor: A LOT OF PLAYERS AND
COACHES HAVE SOMEWHAT IFS.
IF ONLY WE COULD HAVE DONE THIS.
THAT WAS 2009 GAME TWO AND HE
WAS ACTUALLY COMING OFF OF
49-POINT PERFORMANCE IN GAME ONE
THAT FINAL HIGHLIGHT THAT WE
SAW.
ANOTHER REMINDER, THESE WERE ALL
FAN DEVOTED OVER 100,000 FANS
VOTED IN THE APP FOR THESE
HIGHLIGHTS, FOR THE ORDER.
HOW DO YOU THINK THE FANS HAVE
DONE SO FAR IN THEIR SELECTION?
>> I THINK IT IS GREAT.
I THINK PEOPLE FORGET WHAT A
DISRESPECTFUL GAME-WINNER THAT
WAS AGAINST TORONTO.
NEVER IN MY YEARS OF LIVING HAVE
I SEEN SOMEONE SHOOT A RUNNER
GOING LEFT OVER TWO DEFENDERS
LIKE JUST LIKE HOW DO YOU HAVE
THE AUDACITY TO SHOOT THAT?
YOU DON'T PRACTICE THAT.
IT JUST SHOWS YOU, LIKE, HE ON A
DIFFERENT LEVEL.
>> Taylor: I FEEL LIKE LeBRON
IS NOT SHORT ON AUDACITY.
DID YOU HAVE THAT SAME SHOT?
>> Nick: I THINK THAT YOU CAN,
HE SHOULD HAVE WHEN MVP.
THE TEAM HE HAD, YOU TOOK HIM TO
THE FINALS AND WHAT HE DID TO
TORONTO WAS SWEET.
>> Taylor: THERE'S ALWAYS THE
DEBATE ABOUT THE YEARS LeBRON
SHOULD HAVE WON MVP.
HOW MANY SHOULD LeBRON HAVE?
HOW MANY MVPs SHOULD LeBRON
HAVE?
>> I WILL SAY SIX TO SEVEN.
>> Taylor: DO YOU ALL AGREE?
>> HE HAS HAD SOME AMAZING
YEARS.
SOMETIMES WE TAKE THINGS FOR
GRANTED AND THE WAY HE UPLIFTS
HIS TEAMMATES.
YOU KNOW, I THINK THAT YOU CAN
SOMEBODY GOT DEFENSIVE PLAY OF
THE YEAR, I THOUGHT HE WAS
ACTUALLY TRYING THAT YOU, SO HE
SHOULD HAVE GOT IT.
HE WAS DIFFERENT THAT HERE ON
DEFENSE, TOO.
YEAH, HE WAS AN ABSOLUTE AND
WILL.
SHE IS ALWAYS IN A RUN FOR
SOMETHING.
HE IS ALWAYS TOP THREE OR TOP
TWO.
>> Taylor: HOW MANY MVPs
SHOULD LeBRON HAVE?
>> MAN, HONESTLY, THEY COULD
HAVE GIVEN IT TO HIM EVERY YEAR
IF THEY WANTED TO.
BUT I FEEL LIKE THEY COULD HAVE
AT LEAST 12.
>> Taylor: OVER HALF OF HIS
CAREER?
>> Nick: FOR SURE.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN COOL TO SEE
HIM WIN EACH YEAR AND EACH YEAR.
>> Taylor: AND THERE IS
SOMETHING TO BE SAID OF HOW YOU
BECOME THE STANDARD THAT
EVERYONE WANTS YOU.
THEY TAKE FOR GRANTED WHAT HE IS
DOING YEAR IN AND YEAR OUT
BECAUSE THE GREATNESS HAS BEEN
SYNONYMOUS WITH LeBRON AND IT
IS ONE OF THE REASONS WE ENJOYED
WATCHING HIM.
I THINK WE HAVE ANOTHER FIVE
CHECK.
BY AT&T 5G.
LET'S CHECK IN WITH THE
COMMENTATORS.
I'M NOT SURE HOW YOU CANNOT CALL
HIM THE GOAT.
IMAGINE IF LeBRON DID A DUNK
CONTEST.
IT IS COOL TO SEE WHAT HE MEANS
TO OTHER PLAYERS.
I THINK THAT IS ONE OF THE COOL
THINGS.
YOU KNOW FOR THE YOUNG GUYS,
LeBRON HAS ALWAYS BEEN
EVERYTHING.
HE IS PROBABLY ONE OF THE
REASONS SOME OF THEM ARE PLAYING
BASKETBALL.
HAVE YOU SEEN THIS?
>> DEFINITELY.
YOU GO TO THE OTHER TEAMS, LIKE,
WHAT DOES HE DO?
HOW MUCH DOES HE WORK OUT?
THEY ARE TRYING TO GET THE
PAPER.
CALL HIM.
REACH OUT TO HIM AND I HAVE SEEN
A LOT OF PLAYERS TRY TO KEEP UP
WITH HIM.
I WANT TO DO WHAT LeBRON --
IT IS WILD TO SEE BUT HE IS
INSPIRING THE NEXT GENERATION
AND ELEVATING THE GAME, TOTAL
PLAYERS.
>> Taylor: VIBE CHECK, POWERED
BY AT&T 5G.
LET'S GO BACK TO.
AT WHAT IS UP?
>> Pierre: THANKS, WE ARE BACK
WITH ANOTHER VIBE CHECK, PARA BY
AT&T 5G.
I'M HERE WITH LEIGH.
SO I HAVE TO KNOW WHAT IS THEIR
PERSONAL FAVORITE HIGHLIGHT?
>> GREATEST MOMENT.
OH, WHEN HE WON THE
CHAMPIONSHIP.
LAKERS 2020.
>> Pierre: YOU WERE AT THE
PARADE?
>> PARADE, EVERYTHING.
>> Pierre: HOPEFULLY THAT
HIGHLIGHT MADE THE LIST.
WE WANT TO CONTINUE SO WE GOT
YOU TWO TICKETS TO GO SEE BRAUN
AND THE LAKERS UP CLOSE AND
PERSONAL.
HAVE FUN.
TAYLOR, BACK TO YOU.
>> Taylor: THANKS SO MUCH,
PIERRE.
I LOVE THAT.
FOR EVERYONE A IN HERE, WE HAVE
REACHED THE TOP FIVE HIGHLIGHTS.
ARE YOU READY?
LET'S DO IT.
LET'S START WITH NUMBER FIVE.
>> FAVORITE PLAY BY LeBRON.
>> HE GOT SO MANY PLAYS MAN.
IT IS HARD TO CHOOSE.
THE FIRST DUNK HE DID WITH THE
LAKERS.
THAT WAS JUST LIKE KOBE'S.
IT WAS PROBABLY MY FAVORITE P
PLAY.
>> SHOW US SOMETHING LeBRON
DID.
♪
>> Taylor: IF I HAD A FAVORITE,
I WOULD SAY IT IS THAT WHAT THAT
WAS LESS THAN TWO WEEKS AFTER
KOBE PAST.
WHAT DO YOU REMEMBER?
>> Nick: WHEN YOU SEE THE
SIDE-BY-SIDE, YOU GET MORE
EMOTIONAL AND IT MAKES THE DUNK
LOOK MORE INTENSE.
IT IS JUST A DOPE MOMENT FOR
BASKETBALL, WHEN L.A. AND THE
WORLD WAS MOURNING, THAT WAS
DOPE.
THAT WAS DOPE.
>> Taylor: FOR SURE AND FOR YOU,
ALSO, JUST KNOWING AND HAVING
THAT PRESENCE OF MIND TO DO WHAT
WAS THE BEST TRIBUTE FOR KOBE.
>> IT IS WILD.
MOST PEOPLE ARE JUST LIKE LET ME
JUST MAKE THAT PLAY.
HE IS NOT?
LET ME GO INTO MY MEMORY BANK
AND IT JUST SHOWS YOU HIS MIND
IS WORKING A THOUSAND TIMES.
THE GAME OF BASKETBALL IS SO
SLOW TO HIM.
I -- PEOPLE IF THEY HAVE SEEN ME
TALK ABOUT -- HIS MIND IS
LITERALLY A COMPUTER.
I WAS LIKE, MAN, YOU REMEMBER
THAT TIME I, YOU IN PHOENIX?
HE WAS LIKE, WHAT GAME?
I WAS LIKE, REMEMBER WHEN WE BE
YOU KNOW SHE WAS LIKE, YOU ONLY
BEAT US IN 2011.
IT WAS CRAZY.
THE ONLY TIME IT WAS BECAUSE THE
AND THEN I SWITCHED ON YOU.
SO I SAID, MAN, GET OUT OF HERE.
I WENT AND CHECKED THE TAPE AND
IT WAS LITERALLY EVERYTHING WAS
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT.
HE WAS CALLING OUT OUR PLAYS
FROM 2011.
THIS IS 2016 AND I WAS LIKE,
MAN, YOU'VE DIFFERENT.
YOU DIFFERENT.
>> Taylor: AND WE HAVE SEEN FOR
THOSE MOMENTS WHERE SOMEONE ASKS
A QUESTION AND HE TELLS US
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED.
DO YOU HAVE A STORY SUMMER TO
THAT?
>> Nick: I HAVE NEVER HAD THE
CHANCE TO PLAY WITH LeBRON.
I JUST PLAY AGAINST HIM, YOU
KNOW, CALLING OUT THINGS I WAS
GOING TO DO AND LAUGHING ABOUT
IT.
HE KNEW I WAS NOT GOING TO PASS
>> Taylor: YOU ARE SAYING YOU
ARE PLAYING AGAINST LeBRON AND
LeBRON SAYS TO YOU WHAT YOU
ARE ABOUT TO DO AND YOU STILL
DID IT.
>> Channing: THIS, A STORY.
I THINK IT IS DETROIT OR
TORONTO.
ONE OF THE GUYS WAS NOT PAYING
ATTENTION.
LeBRON, I'M RIGHT THERE NEXT
TO HIM.
YOU GOT TO STAND IN THE CORNER.
GO ACROSS TO HIS TEAMMATE.
HE IS LIKE, THANKS, MAN.
HE DOES THE PLAY.
YEAH, MAN, SET THE SCREEN AND
THEN YOU'RE GOING TO GO UP, DO
THIS.
I'M LIKE, NO WAY.
SURE ENOUGH, DOES THAT THING AND
I THINK EVEN THE ROSEN WAS LIKE
THAT IS DIFFERENT.
FOR HIM TO KNOW EVERYONE ON THE
COURT ALL THE TIME IS CRAZY.
>> Taylor: LET'S LOOK AT NUMBER
FOUR.
♪
>> CRAZY, THE HIGHLIGHTS YOU
HAVE GIVEN US, UNBELIEVABLE.
UNFORTUNATE, I WAS PART OF ONE
OF THOSE HIGHLIGHTS.
I'M REMINDED OF IT ALL THE TIME.
HOW DID YOU WHEN LeBRON DUMPED
OVER YOU?
>> HE GOES RIGHT OVER LEWIS.
I DID NOT SAY THAT PLAY
RITUALLY.
IT IS IS LIKE A STEP LADDER.
>> SALUTE.
♪
>> Taylor: I MEAN, DOES IT GET
MORE YIKES THAN THAT?
>> DON'T LET HIM REPLAY IT.
AS ONE MEN TO ANOTHER, YOU GOT
TO SAY SOMETHING TO HIM.
I GOT KIDS.
YOU CANNOT PUT ME ON LIKE THAT.
>> Taylor: YOU AT LEAST HAVE TO
ACT LIKE YOU ARE GOING TO FIGHT.
>> HE KICKED ME!
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> Taylor: IF THAT IS YOU CAN
THAT MOMENT, TELL ME WHAT YOU DO
RIGHT AFTER.
>> Nick: FOR ME, I'M AT LEAST
GOING TO THROW THE BALL.
I WILL GET A TAPE SOMEHOW.
>> Taylor: I DON'T NEED TO BE IN
THE GAME ANYMORE.
>> Channing: TAKE THAT SHOES
OFF, THAT IS IT.
>> Nick: 2 FEET OVER ME.
>> Taylor: IN TERMS OF
DISRESPECTFUL --
>> Channing: THAT IS -- IT IS
DIFFERENT BECAUSE HE IS PROBABLY
6-FOOT.
ONE HUMAN BEING JUMPING OVER
ANOTHER GROWN MAN IS EXTREMELY
DISRESPECTFUL.
>> Taylor: HONESTLY, HIM NOT
FALLING IS ALMOST WORSE.
BECAUSE IT IS LIKE, I BASICALLY
CLEARED YOU TO GET TO THAT.
>> LIKE SUPER MARIO.
>> Taylor: HIT THE GROUND.
THERE WAS A LOT OF CONTACT.
PARKS I LOVE THAT.
SHOUT-OUT TO JOHN BEING A GOOD
SPORT THROUGHOUT THESE YEARS.
WE ARE ALMOST DONE.
NUMBER THREE.
POP MUSIC MAC.
>> LeBRON.
>> LeBRON WAS IN CLEVELAND AND
THEY WERE PLAYING IN THE
PLAYOFFS.
ACTUALLY HAD TO GET AN IE --
I.V. OUT IS THAT GAME.
I DROVE DOWN TO DETROIT BECAUSE
IT WAS CRAZY TO SEE ALL THE
SHOTS THAT HE WAS MAKING.
>> HE HAS SCORED THE LAST 25
POINTS FOR CLEVELAND.
>> JAMES SCORES WITH AN
IMPROBABLE VICTORY.
>> I WILL NEVER FORGET.
>> Taylor: 22 YEARS OLD AND THAT
HIGHLIGHT.
HE DID THAT WITH 48 POINTS NINE
REBOUNDS.
SEVEN ASSISTS.
22.
>> I THINK THAT IS ONE OF THE
MOST UNDERRATED CHAMPIONS
DEFENSIVELY.
THEY WERE DEMONS AND WHEN HE
STARTED GOING OFF, DUNKING LIKE
THAT, YOU DIFFERENT.
HE IS THAT AND EVERYTHING.
LIKE, HALL OF FAMER.
YOU LOOK AT WALLIS AND THERE WAS
NOTHING -- THERE WERE
DOUBLE-TEAMING.
ANYWHERE HE WANTED TO GET TO, HE
GOT TO ADD 25 STRAIGHT POINTS
AND THE NBA, WHAT YOU GO IN A
STREAK OF 12 OR 14, YOU GET A
DOUBLE-TEAM.
25 IN A ROW COULD NOT YOU GET
TRIPLE TEAM.
YOU ARE STILL BARBECUING.
>> Taylor: I SEE YOU WATCHING
THOSE.
YOU THINK ABOUT THAT FINALS
RIGHT THERE, WHAT REALLY STICKS
OUT?
>> Nick: THE CRAZY THINGS LIKE
OFFENSIVE BAG AND THAT YOU LOOK
AT THAT AND SEE THE CROSS OVER
AND YOU SEE THE BEHIND THE BACK,
YOU SEE THREE PEOPLE GUARDING
HIM.
LIKE, IT IS UNBELIEVABLE THE
HATE HE GETS AND PEOPLE SAY HE
CAN SCORE.
LOOK AT THIS AND IT IS CRAZY.
>> Taylor: WHAT DO YOU THINK IS
THE MOST UNDERRATED ASPECT OF
LeBRON'S GAME?
>> Nick: I WOULD SAY HIS HANDLE.
I SEE LeBRON CROSSING PEOPLE
OVER.
HE HAS SOMEBODY BETWEEN THE
LEGS, CROSSOVER.
I WOULD SAY HIS HANDLE TO GET
THAT STRONG.
YEAH.
>> Channing: IT IS DEFINITELY
HIS HANDLE.
YOU THOUGHT THAT CLIP WHAT HE
WENT UNDERNEATH THE LEGS.
JAMES HARDEN WAS DOING THAT IN
HOUSTON.
SO LeBRON SEASON SOMETHING
ANOTHER ELITE PLAYER IS GOING
AND HE WAS PRACTICING THAT WITH
TRISTIN.
HE WAS PRACTICING DOING THAT
MOVE OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
THE TEAMS WERE TRYING TO COME
BACK.
SO HE WAS PRACTICING THAT AND
USUALLY WHEN YOU PRACTICE OVER A
WEEK, TWO WEEKS, YOU ARE
PRACTICING ONE TIME AND THEN I'M
LIKE, COME ON, MAN.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO WORK ON
THAT A LITTLE BIT MORE?
HE GOES AND DOES IT AND THAT
SAME DAY THAT HE DECIDED THAT HE
WAS GOING TO WORK ON IT.
>> Taylor: ABSOLUTELY.
WE ARE NEARING THE END.
LET'S LOOK AT NUMBER TWO.
PARKS.
>> MY FAVORITE LeBRON PLAY, I
WOULD SAY THE ALLEY-OOP AND
BOSTON.
>> IT IS OVER.
>> MY FAVORITE LeBRON PLAY
WOULD HAVE TO BE WHAT HE CAUGHT
ON DYSENTERY.
>> THE LAUB AGAINST BOSTON.
THAT IS PROBABLY MY FAVORITE.
>> SMASHED IT DOWN AND STARED
HIM DOWN!
>> Taylor: OF COURSE, THEY WON
THAT GAME.
IT WAS THEIR 23rd WHEN, IN A
ROW AND IT WAS EVENTUALLY A 27
WINNING GAME.
DO YOU GUYS REMEMBER THIS ONE
PRETTY HEAVILY, I'M SURE IT?
>> I WAS -- I GOT A WEIRD SENSE
OF HUMOR.
I CRACKED UP WATCHING JUST HOW
HE FELT LIKE A BABY FALLING DOWN
THE STAIRS.
JUST LAID THERE.
AND I ASKED, WHAT WERE YOU
THINKING?
HE WAS LIKE, I DID NOT KNOW
UNTIL IT WAS TOO LATE.
HE THOUGHT IT WAS MARIO
CHALMERS, BIG FELLOW.
>> Taylor: AFTER THIS, LeBRON
TALKED ABOUT HOW HAPPY HE WAS
THAT IT WAS -- BECAUSE JET IS A
TRASH TALKER AND IT WAS LIKE,
I'M HAPPY THAT IT WAS HIM.
IS LeBRON ALSO A TRASH TALKER
OR IS HE MORE LIKE I'M GOING TO
SHOW YOU?
>> Nick: WHEN IT COMES TO THE
ARIZONA GUYS, THEY TALKED A LOT.
YOU GOT TO SHOW THEM.
THAT WILL BE ON YOUTUBE FOREVER.
HIS KIDS ARE GOING TO SEE THAT.
SO I'M HAPPY IT HAPPEN TO
SOMEBODY THAT WENT TO ARIZONA.
>> Taylor: IF I COULD DUNK ON
CHANNING, I WOULD.
[ LAUGHTER ]
YOU GUYS, WE HAVE ONE MORE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IT IS?
FEEL FREE TO CALL IT OUT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
OH, I GOT A LOT OF PEOPLE SAYING
THE BLOCK AND THEY MIGHT BE
RIGHT.
LET'S LOOK AT NUMBER ONE.
>> MY FAVORITE ONE IS THE BLOCK
AT GOLDEN STATE.
BUT I THOUGHT THAT WAS AN
AMAZING PLAY.
>> UP TO THAT LAMP!
BLOCKED BY JAMES!
LeBRON JAMES WITH THE
REJECTION.
>> IT WAS AMAZING.
THE WAY HE GOT BACK AND TO MAKE
A PLAY LIKE THAT.
>> I WOULD SAY THAT BLOCK AT
GOLDEN STATE.
PROTECTING BOTH SIDES OF THE
RIM.
HE IS THE ONLY PERSON IN THE
WORLD THAT CAN MAKE THAT PLAY.
FOR ARGUABLY THE GREATEST PLAYER
TO HAVE EVER PLAYED THE GAME.
♪
>> Taylor: THERE WAS NO OTHER,
RIGHT?
>> DEFINITELY NOT.
BECAUSE I WAS WATCHING J.R.
DURING THAT YEAR, SO BRON,
YELLING AT HIM, JUST SO HE CAN'T
JUST DUNK IT.
I GOT THE BEST SEAT IN THE HOUSE
AND I SEE THIS BLACK BLUR GO
BACK -- BY MY FACE AND TO HAVE
THE WHEREWITHAL TO NOT HANG ON
THE RIM AND TO NOT THROW ANDRE
AND KEEP THE BALL IN PLAY IS A
WILD -- IT IS NOT NORMAL.
IT IS NOT REGULAR PEOPLE,
REGULAR NBA PLAYERS, MOST
ALL-STARS, DO THAT.
AND THAT WAS JUST ONE OF THE
WILDEST MOMENTS.
I WAS LIKE, LET ME GO TO THE
BACK.
I WILL HAVE A HEART ATTACK HERE.
>> Taylor: AND THERE WAS SOME
HARDWARE.
YOU KNOW THAT IT IS A GOOD
HIGHLIGHT WHEN IT HAS ITS OWN
WIKIPEDIA PAGE.
THE BLOCK HAS IT WIKIPEDIA PAGE.
EVEN THE FIRST LINE OF THAT
WIKIPEDIA PAGE IS --
>> THE BLOCK.
>> Taylor: PERIOD, THAT IS ALL
YOU NEED.
WHAT DO YOU TALKED ABOUT IN THE
LOCKER ROOM?
>> HOW DRUNK WE ARE GOING TO
GET.
WE ARE EXHAUSTED, THE FOCUS IT
TOOK AND THAT TEAM WAS SO GOOD.
WE MADE FIVE MISTAKES AND THEY
SCORED 15 POINTS.
THAT IS HOW GOOD GOLDEN STATE
IS.
WE HAD TO PLAY PERFECT.
PEOPLE FORGET ABOUT KEVIN LOVE
BLACKING OUT.
AND THEN THE BLOCK.
IT WAS JUST EVERYONE HAD TO DO
THEIR JOBS THAT ARE THE BEST OF
THEIR ABILITY AND EVERYONE KNEW
EVERYONE'S PLAYS.
IT WAS JUST LIKE EXHAUSTION.
EVEN FOR ME BECAUSE BASED ON
PAYCHECKS, I KNEW I WAS NOT
GOING TO PLAY IN THESE GAMES.
>> Nick: THE EMOTIONS ON THE
BENCH.
>> Channing: I'M GOOD.
>> LIKE, PUT ME IN, COACH.
I HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE
AUDIENCE.
WE HAVE HEARD FROM A LOT OF
DIFFERENT PLAYERS ABOUT THEIR
FAVORITE LeBRON MOMENTS.
SHOULD WE HEAR FROM LeBRON
ABOUT HIS FAVORITE MOMENT THAT
YOU THINK?
LET'S SEE WHAT LeBRON HAD TO
SAY ABOUT LeBRON?
>> LeBron: MY FAVORITE MOMENT,
MAN, I THINK IT WAS THE FIRST
MAKE THAT I HAD, THE BASELINE.
>> LeBRON JAMES' FIRST SHOT IS
GOOD.
>> LeBron: THAT WAS THAT MOMENT
WHERE I WAS LIKE, OH, MAN, I CAN
DO THIS.
I CAN REALLY DO THIS ON THE
SHFIRST SHOT.
I WAS LIKE, I'M HERE NOW.
LET'S ROCK.
>> Taylor: I LOVE THAT HE HAD 25
POINTS IN THAT DEBUT AND WENT ON
TO WIN ROOKIE OF THE YEAR.
THAT IS STILL THE MOST POINTS BY
A PREP TO PRO.
SO DEFINITELY AN ICONIC MOMENT
BUT I THINK IT WAS THE EASY
ANSWER FOR LeBRON.
>> SOMETIMES -- I MADE MY FIRST
SHOT.
I COULD BE AN ALL-STAR.
THAT IS DIFFERENT.
I MAKE THE FIRST ONE AND THAT IS
STRAIGHT DOWN TO A KEYHOLE.
YEAH, I DON'T KNOW IF I BELONG
HERE.
GOT NOBODY ELSE TO PUT IN.
>> Taylor: I THINK THE FANS DID
A GOOD JOB OF VOTING.
FIRST UP, GIVE IT UP FOR
YOURSELVES AND FOR THESE
HIGHLIGHTS.
WAS THERE ANY MAJOR, MAJOR ONES
THAT MISSED THAT WERE NOT ALSO
IN THE BEGINNING?
>> THERE WERE SOME MISSED DUNKS
THAT HE HAD AGAINST THE PORTLAND
TRAILBLAZERS.
HE MISSED AN ALLEY-OOP.
DO YOU REMEMBER THAT?
>> YEAH.
>> AND THEN IN THE FINALS GAME,
AFTER THE BLOCK, AFTER ALL THAT,
WHEN HE TRIED TO DUNK ON
DRE'MONT AND GOT FOULED, HIS
HEAD IS UP BY THE RIM AND HE
ALREADY PLAYED 46 MINUTES.
FOR HIM TO GO THAT HIGH IN THE
GAME WAS CRAZY.
IT WAS ONE OF THE BEST I HAVE
SEEN.
>> Taylor: FOR SURE.
20 YEARS OF GREATNESS.
I KNOW WE ALL WISH THERE COULD
BE 20 MORE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE LEAGUE IS
GOING TO BE LIKE WITHOUT
LeBRON?
>> OH, PIMENTA IT IS GOING TO BE
TEST.
LeBRON BRINGS A LOT AND EVERY
TIME, LIKE, YOU GET KOBE LEAVING
AND THEN LeBRON AND KOBE AND
THE SAME TIME BUT IT IS GOING TO
BE HARD.
IT WILL BE HARD.
AS LONG AS YOU KEEP -- HE KEEPS
PAYING HIS MONEY FOR HIS BODY HE
MIGHT BE HERE LONGER.
>> Taylor: 20 MORE YEARS.
>> Nick: TOM BRADY.
>> Taylor: THERE'S A LIVE LOOK
AT LeBRON.
YOU KNOW THAT GAME IS COMING.
I WANT US TO LOOK TO THE FUTURE.
LET'S SAY IN 20 YEARS, WE ALL
ARE BACK TOGETHER.
WHO IS ANOTHER PLAYER YOU CAN
SEE DOING 20 YEARS OF GREATNESS
HIGHLIGHT PACKAGE, CHATTING?
>> Channing: MAYBE YUNUS.
I THINK HE IS DEDICATED TO THE
GAME BUT WE WILL NEVER SEE
ANYONE DO WHAT LeBRON IS
DOING.
I THINK 70 TOLD ME SOMEBODY
WOULD HAVE TO START GOING TO THE
PLAYOFFS WHEN THEY WERE 18 AND
AVERAGE 23 FOR 20 IS, THAT EVEN
BE CLOSE TO WHAT HE IS DOING.
THAT IS WHAT IS CRAZY.
THAT CONSISTENCY, THE HIGHEST
LEVEL.
REGULAR SEASON STUFF, I KNOW A
LOT OF PLAYERS THAT CAN DO
REGULAR SEASON STUFF.
BRING THE SEASON AWARDS.
HE IS DIFFERENT WHEN THEY PUT
THAT REAL LIGHTS ON AND THAT IS
WHAT HAS BEEN AMAZING,
ESPECIALLY FOR A GUY WHO IS
GOING TO BREAK THE SCORING
RECORD THIS YEAR.
KNOCK ON WOOD.
MAKE SOME MORE THREES.
>> Taylor: EVERYONE ON THAT TEAM
BETTER MAKE SOME MORE THREES.
FOR YOU ALL WATCHING AT HOME,
FLIPPED ON OVER TO THE TNT.
CLIPPERS/LAKERS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ABLE
ENERGY, FOR BEING HERE.
WE APPRECIATE IT AND ALSO,
SECOND HALF NBA TWITTER LIVE.
WE WILL BE TALKING OVER THE GAME
OVER THERE AT CRYPTO ARENA,
WHICH I ALWAYS STILL WANT TO
CALL IT STAPLES.
YES.
[LAUGHS] THANK YOU SO MUCH,
NICK.
THANKS, CHATTING.
THANK YOU ALL.
ENJOY THE GAME.
♪
-- Captions by VITAC --
www.vitac.com